I'm back in my element I got three movie
reviews coming to you so let's do some
damage control battle Los Angeles or
battle LA whatever so battle LA is an
alien invasion movie that a lot of
people hate it I was personally looking
forward to this movie so when I saw
critics bashing it I was a little I
don't know I was sad and the premise is
really simple aliens come and we fight
them yeah that's it so there's a squad
led by I don't know someone I've never
seen before but the main character is
Aaron Eckhart aka two-face and they have
to go get civilians out of this blast
zone before we wipe the place out with
bombs now I will say this the movies not
as bad as I heard it was I know a lot of
people were like Jeremy you got to
review this movie you got to beat the
out of it it's worse than skyline
but it's not worse than skyline it's not
it's also not as good as I wanted it to
be so there is that it has the exciting
parts and they are cooling that happen
it has the slow parts and they are
boring but ultimately nothing felt like
that alien invasion movie where it's
like you know what it's us versus them
Armageddon is gonna happen if we fail
although that is the case the movie
ultimately looks and feels like a video
game it's like Call of Duty a lot of
times it felt like Mass Effect like they
get ambushed and they take cover and
then you see the enemy like taking cover
and shooting and they're getting closer
and closer yeah you know that whole
feeling and in that the movies pretty
fun but also in that it's not about
aliens it's about the squad and in that
it doesn't feel like an alien invasion
movie which is what everyone wanted to
see that's actually the main problem
right there they concentrate so much on
the human characters that the aliens
don't matter the movie could have been
about an invasion by Bionic lesbian nuns
led by Charlie Sheen and it would have
felt exactly the same because the movies
not about aliens or any other antagonist
it's about the protagonist the Marines
which ultimately makes it feel like a
lesser and grade B version of Black Hawk
Down so why not just watch Black Hawk
Down I have no good reason why not to so
there's that
I like Aaron Eckhart he's a badass and
he even has a couple of those speeches
you know like the Bill Pullman speech
and Independence Day only you know I
will say that about the movie the movie
doesn't end on any note like uploading a
computer virus to an incompatible OS
that always annoyed me we do it with
bombs in this movie which is how it
should be so is it a cool movie kind of
is it a fulfilling movie no is it a
live-action video game absolutely and
like I said I didn't hate the movie as
much as a lot of other people in fact
when I
the movie I was like it's a pretty good
time no alcohol required but a day later
I do not give a about the movie at
all I haven't thought of it all day so I
ultimately got to say it's okay but
you're not going to remember it in
t-minus one sleep cycle because that's
pretty much the facts but if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more